hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today we're going to
be going over the Traxler counter-attack
which is one of my favourite defenses
from black it is one of the most
aggressive openings that you can play as
black you often won't get opportunity to
play it but if you do have an opponent
that really enjoys the Italian game
which is pretty much what it comes from
then you will have more opportunities
than not to try this out so it starts
out again with the Italian game pawn e4
pawn e5 Knight f3 simple development
move from white trying to control the
center black responds knight c6 trying
to do the same and then the bishop comes
to c4 this is the Italian game and
blacks going to play the to Knight
defense so this is kind of where it all
stems from right here
but now White's going to play Knight to
g5 again attacking this square on f7 and
white excuse me black really has to
decide what he wants to do now a lot of
times from here you will see black go
into the fried liver attack as far as
the defense side from black which
basically looks like pawn to d5 trying
to break up this to attack on the f7
square but the Traxler counter-attack
pretty much it says I don't even care
that my f7 squared which is the weakest
square for black at the beginning of the
game is being attacked instead I'm going
to bring my Bishop to c5 and I'm going
to attack the other square this pawn on
f2 this is the weakest Square from white
so if you're going to attack my f7
square I'm going to attack your f2
Square right away we can see both sides
have very very deadly attacks going on
against the King in this video
exclusively we're going to be talking
about what happens when the knight takes
on f7 which is what I see most of the
time this knife here cannot be taken
from this King on e8 and at the same
time he's attacking the Queen on d8 and
the rook here on h8 so as far as a
material standpoint this is a very good
move from white but black has other
ideas and his idea is to come down and
attack the King here on a1 he's going to
sacrifice this Bishop on f2 to try to
lure out the King and just try to have a
deadly attack on this King here so why
does have a lot of different options
some of the options obviously would be
to f1 obviously you can come to e2 and
he can take on f2
so we're going to kind of be going over
those three different options that white
has and kind of go over some of the main
concepts that you'll see from black
while you want to attack the king over
and over because again this is very
aggressive from black and you're not
giving up this bishop on f2 and you're
not letting your queen on d8 and your
rook here on h8 just sit there being
attacked by this night for no reason
you're going to attack and you're going
to attack the entire game so the first
thing we're going to look at is that the
King takes on f2 which seems like a
logical moves office and he wants to get
as much material as it can he knows that
he's going to have to move his king
somewhere his being under attacked right
here from the bishop on f2 so he knows
he can no longer castle and his Kings
not going to be safe so he might as well
take as much material as they can now
from here as you can see the best move
from black here is going to bring his
Knight to e4 attacking the King here and
at the same time freeing up this Queen
on d8 to get out of the way obviously he
doesn't want to lose his Queen on d8 if
he doesn't have to with the night here
on f7 so what is he going to do he's
going to make away at the same time he's
gaining a tempo by attacking the King
here on f2 now black white from here
does have a lot of different options
obviously he can come back to f1 if he
wants to he can come back to g1 the best
move really is going to be g1 although
it kind of looks really passive from
white his rook is obviously blocked in
he's not going to be able to use this
rook anytime soon from here black has
two options he can really bring his
Queen to h4 or he can also bring his
Queen to e7 obviously one he wants to
get his queen involved into the game at
the same time he does not want to lose
this Queen from this night here on f7 so
the more aggressive moves you can tell
is Queen to h4 really starting a attack
on the King side from white here it's
going to be really hard for white to
defend the entire game now keep in mind
from both sides if you do play correctly
there are some great defenses and some
great attacks from the white and the
black side so I'm not going to go over
every single line because there are
thousands of them but I do want to kind
of go over some of the big ideas so
that's d1 again this is probably the
best move but it does look pretty
passive
if white really hasn't played this a lot
it's really hard to kind of find this a
lot of times from here you will just see
white retreat back to f1 from here again
black can come to h4 again not only is
this getting involved into the game his
rook here on h8 is safe because again
black has a one move checkmate here on
f2 if white does not defend very well at
the same time keep in mind that this
Knight here is very very potent at the
same time black anytime he wants to can
bring another night here on d4 which is
going to attack very well from here
white may bring his queen to f3 again he
has to try to defend against this square
here on f2 from here black can just go
ahead and start to attack more as we
talked about he is now bringing his
knight to d4 he has a lot of different
attacks going on anytime he wants to he
can castle on the King side and really
have his rook eye down on this F Island
this is going to be really hard for
white to really cope with again he is he
doesn't have his a rook he doesn't have
his knight or his dark square bishop in
the game it is white knight over here on
h1 is very passive so a lot of different
variations you can see for black very
very strong attack that black hat we can
go and continue and just show you some
of the variations that you will see from
here the palm might come to g3 the Queen
could now come down to h3 attacking
checking the King if the Queen tries to
come to g2 obviously why it would really
just like the trade off material anytime
you're being pressured if you can pretty
much exchange pieces that will kind of
alleviate some of the pressure that your
opponent has but now the Queen can come
back to f5 a much better Square for the
for the Queen here really puts a lot of
pressure on white if the King now moves
back to e 1 because again the Queen
can't move here because now the square
on f2 is now being attacked twice by
this Knight here and this Queen here
from f5 so now that I can come to c2 and
forking both the rook here on a1 and
attacking the King here on e1 so a lot
of different attacks as we talked about
that black hasn't it's going to be
really hard for white to defend against
all these attack
a worse move that you may see from white
if they just get really flustered
obviously we are attacking them with
tempo is they could bring their King
back to Ebola this is a problem because
the king the queen is going to come to
h4 regardless but after the Queen comes
to h4 we're also gaining another tempo
we're attacking the king here if he
tries to now block us on g3 then our
knight can come in and take on g3 now if
he recaptures with his pawn from h2 to
g3 then the Queen can now come to h1 as
you can see pretty much White's entire
Queen side is undeveloped it's going to
be really hard for him to bring out his
pieces at the same time at all though
black is down in material
he really has a really strong attack
here obviously this King is just pretty
much going to be running around the
board the entire game and this Queen is
very very strong from here the bishop
may come to f1 again if the king came to
e 2 this would be a huge mistake
the knight could come to f4 getting more
and more pieces involved into the game
and the Queen's going to be lost here so
obviously the best move from here would
be the Bishop comes down to f1 from here
black can castle on the King side again
he doesn't want to lose this rook and he
still wants to be able to castle and
this rook here on f8 is going to be very
very strong obviously eyeing down on
this f1 square if we have a rook and a
queen both eyeing down on this f1 square
again any any more attack that black has
on white it's just going to be that much
harder for white to to thin so from here
you may see the Queen come to e2 a
guinea has said he has to do something
to try to defend against this f1 square
because his kings not going anywhere and
this business sure is not to go anywhere
and trying to pretty much developing
these pieces right now it's going to be
way too late
so from here the knight can come to d4
again just adding more and more pressure
onto this side now the Queen comes to g2
trying to exchange off pieces now from
here black can go ahead and exchange off
pieces if he wants to he can go ahead
and take on g2 and after he takes on
here then the knight can come in and
capture on c2 and forking this King here
so if the King moves then we can come in
on a2 and as you can
see black is fine and material obviously
at the same time he has both a visit
rooks here and he has a very very good
game the the King has just been run all
over the game black does have more pawns
here so this is going to be an easy win
for black and this all stems from the
very very potent attack that black had
from the beginning now keep in mind he
could take on f2 but he does not have to
a lot of times you may run into a tricky
player that says you know what you're
kind of gambling up this bishop here on
f2 and I know you're gonna gain a tempo
when you capture here on e4 with your
knight
so instead I'm in there I'm either going
to bring my king to f1 or I'm going to
bring my king to e2 in this case we'll
talk about f1 now black does have a lot
of options right here
but typically his first move is going to
be Queen to e7 as you can tell right
away black cannot gain a tempo with an
attack on the King so right away he
doesn't want to lose his Queen obviously
his queen is sitting here being attacked
by the knight and since there's not
going to be any forced win right away
first thing he needs to do is get his
Queen to safety now from here why does
somewhat safe obviously there are a lot
of attacks that black has but for the
most part white really wants to just
start taking material as much as you can
so from here black is going to play pawn
to d5 keep in mind this is pretty much a
standard what you're going to see with
the Queen coming to b7 and then your
pawn coming to d5 now white does have
two options here the most logical is
going to be pawn to d5 we always want to
capture with your pawns and being
supported by your minor pieces in the
beginning of the game so from here after
the pawn takes on d5 then the Knights
going to come to d4 really getting
involved into the game obviously he's
being attacked from this pawn on d5 so
he wants to not only avoid being
captured but he wants to get involved
into the game she can see right here not
only is this Knight very active but he's
also threatening taking on c2 which is
going to take this rook here on a1 so
from here it's most logical for the pawn
to come to c3 and this does two thing
one it really attacks this night here on
d4 so we can see but it also gives way
for the Queen to move out of
way anytime this bishop this
light-square bishop for black wants to
come into the game obviously this is
going to be a lost cause for whites
Queen once we have the night here on d4
so he really wants not only attack this
but he wants to give way for his queen
to get out of the way now the bishop can
come to g4 obviously getting another
minor piece involved into the game at
the same time gaining a tempo by
attacking the Queen here now the Queen
obviously needs to move so more than
likely the Queen will come to a4 trying
to get a tempo by attacking the King
here on e a white really has excuse me
black really has two moves he can bring
his bishop back to excuse me he can
bring his bishop back to d7 or as we
just saw he can bring his Knight to d7
now I find that it's a lot more
aggressive for black to bring his Knight
to d7 obviously we just brought our
Bishop out so there's really no reason
in my head to bring the Bishop back to
d7 and again the bishop in this open
space here really puts a lot more
pressure on white here so you can always
defend with Knight to d7 and then white
can from here take our Bishop here on f2
again really just trying to by the way
at all the material that he can since he
is in a lot of pressure
anytime you you have a lot of pressure
on you you want to gobble up as many
pieces as you can to try to alleviate
some of that pressure from here the
Queen's going to come to h4 s you can
start to see black has a really really
strong attack here going and it's really
hard for white this entire game to try
to figure out the best way to defend
this now from here the King wants to
come to e3 as you can start to see it's
really starting to involve into a the
white king running around the board you
know we can go as far as you want to
kind of go over all the variations the
Queen can come to g5 really starting to
attack the King there's not a lot of
great places for the King to come Queen
can come to f5 again continuing to
attack after the King now comes to g1
very passive Square this rook no longer
is going to be coming into the game then
black king castle on the key on the
Queen side again this Knight here is
going to fall on h8 if white tries to
gobble up more material let's say pawn
takes on
d for taking the night here we'll just
kind of go in through the rook can come
here to f8 again putting a lot of
pressure
obviously Queen takes or Queen to F one
is going to be checkmate white really
has to defend against that so one of the
moves he can do is pawn to h3 again kind
of giving way for a square for his King
to go from here the Queen can come to f2
attacking the King if the King starts to
run we can sacrifice our bishop after
the King comes then the pawn can come to
g5 and it's going to be good game for
white here it's going to be all over
shoot so as I've talked about many times
in chess it's not always about how many
pieces you have it's about how many
active pieces you have into the game
attacking your opponent so as we can see
even though black is down a crap ton of
material it's going to be very very hard
for white to win this game his dark
square bishop is not doing anything his
both of his rooks are passive his knight
here is still on b1 and his Queens over
here he was trying to gobble up some
material at the same time he's nowhere
in the action he can't really attack our
King because pretty much every move that
black has is attacking the King so just
one of the ideas that you may see now
the last idea that you may come across
and attract slur and we'll go ahead and
go over a famous game by track so this
is kind of what started the entire track
slur counter-attack is we'll go ahead
and start into it with knight takes on
f7 and Bishop takes on f2 now on track
slurs famous game his opponent played
King to e2 we've already talked about
what happens if the King takes on f2
we've also talked about what happen if
King moves to f1 and now we're going to
see King to e2 which is we can see from
this famous game is probably the worst
move ever and Traxler just pretty much
dominated him from the get-go basically
teaching him a lesson on pretty much you
need to know all these crazy openings or
I'm just going to dominate you on the
board so that's what he did so he played
Knight to d4 again getting his minor
pieces involved into the game if you
have a ton of minor pieces in the middle
of the board and the King is just being
chased all over it's
really hard for your opponent to do
anything at the same time it really
allows you just to be creative in chess
the more pieces you have active if
you're chasing around the King it pretty
much just comes down to a big puzzle for
you can you navigate all your pieces
around to checkmate your opponent and
that's pretty much what Traxler did in
this game so from here the king came to
d3 and now the pawn came to b5 now this
is a pretty intense move right here
white pretty much saw that if the night
came on d8 because right away he's not
being attacked here so in some regard he
could try to just gobble up material he
saw that after he takes on d8 that the
pawn could come here take on c4 with the
tempo attacking the king here on d3 and
after he takes the bishop could come to
c6 and after the King moves then the
bishop could come down to e2
the Queen's going to be lost at the same
time Black's going to have a much better
position he's going to be able to take
this night here on d8 at the same time
the white Kings in the middle of the
board like him pretty much still attack
the entire time and he has a much better
position than white does so in this case
in the game as we saw it instead of
taking on d8 the Queen white decided to
instead move his bishop back to b3 now
from here black brought his Knights down
to e4 again just getting ready for the
attack and so from here why decided now
would be a good time to take the Queen
on d8 obviously he didn't realize just
how big of an attack that black had so
from here the King the Knights going to
come to c5 attacking the king on d3 the
King now moves to c3 and then pretty
much it was just game over it was just a
matter of tracks or pretty much using
all his pieces to dominate so from here
the Knights going to come to e2 and this
does a few things one not only does it
check the king forcing white to do a
move but at the same time it frees up
the bishop to come to d4 which is just a
fascinating move in itself so the Queen
is going to capture in the bishop is now
going to come
Toodee for attacking the king here so
the king is going to come to before and
the pawn is going to come to a5
attacking pretty much the rest the game
is just going to be attacking all over
the board so the king is going to take
on b5 anytime your King goes past your
opponent's are past your own fourth rank
it's usually not a good thing usually
means your opponent's just attacking all
over the board so from here the Bishop
came to a6 and after the King took then
the bishop came to d3 now I know myself
I would be just so tempted to go ahead
and take this Queen on e3 or excuse me
on e - but Traxler realized he pretty
much had a mating net all the way so he
knew that when he brought his Bishop to
d3 not only was this a discovered attack
but he also wanted to keep this Bishop
where it was and he really wanted to
keep this Queen out of the way so it's
just kind of a just a extra little
dagger saying I don't even need to take
your queen I'm gonna win regardless so
the king came to b4 and now the knights
going to come to a6 again every move
from now is going to be an attack the
King is going to now come to a3 and
again another discovered attack he's now
sacrificing a night here on before and
after he takes on before then pawn to c5
is checkmate now I don't know how far
along he thought this through but this
is one of the most fascinating attacks
that I've seen in a long time just
sacrifices really getting all his pieces
exactly where they need to be so that he
can win the game with checkmate so hope
you guys enjoyed really what I want to
stress with the Traxler counter-attack
is there's so many variations but it
really allows you as far as black to
really be creative with your attack so
there's many different ways the white
can try to defend he can try to gobble
up more of your pieces he can try to win
that game or you can just try to go into
safety mode and just try to defend his
King the entire game but you pretty much
as black have so many different options
to attack that I really really like this
defense from black so anytime you see
your opponent at the beginning of the
game if you're starting up with the
Italian game
and then you see him try to bring his
Knight to g5 you can just kind of wave
your finger at the computer board and
say hi no sir
I don't even care about this f7 square
and bringing my bishop down to c5 and
then just see what he does he might just
resign right there which would be kind
of funny so I hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you haven't already please
subscribe to the YouTube channel and
check out the website www.chesterlaw.com
and I will see you guys in the next
video thanks for watching